jetpacks für kaum ein anderes level der
zukunft scheint sich menschen so sehr zu
interessieren
von james bond film über tausende von
computerspielen bis hin zu shows im
football-stadion der raketenrucksack ist
überall
aber wie realistisch ist es wirklich
dass wir in ein paar jahren alle mit dem
jetpack zur arbeit fliegen werden
die antwort gibt es jetzt bei lausanne
die geschichte des jetpacks reicht weit
zurück bis ins jahr 1949 wo die us army
ein programm startete das einen
raketenrucksack für ihre soldaten
entwickeln sollte
mit diesem rucksack könnten die us
soldaten ohne viel training über die
köpfe der gegner hinweg fliegen wie ein
bienenschwarm der von allen seiten kommt
wollte sich die armee so den vorteil
über ihren gegner verschaffen
drei jahre später also 1952 gab es dann
den ersten prototypen an einer leine
konnte das jetpack schon einen menschen
wenige sekunden am stück in die luft
befördern
nach diesem erfolg machte das jetpack
über die nächsten jahre unter dem namen
rocket welt immer wieder fortschritte
bis zu 16 kilometer pro stunde schnell
konnte die letzte version des
raketenrucksack werden bis die us armee
das programm offiziell einstellt zu groß
und schwer für die normalen fußsoldaten
würde es den anforderungen der armee
nicht gerecht doch das interesse und die
faszination der öffentlichkeit war
bereits geweckt so ziemlich jedes
jetpack das seitdem entwickelt wurde
stammt von hobby ingenieuren oder von
unabhängigen firmen
deswegen wurde die grundlegende
funktionsweise eines jet packs auch seit
den 50er jahren kaum verbessert
und das ist wahrscheinlich auch der
grund dass wir immer noch nicht zur
arbeit fliegen können
das problem ist dass wir menschen
einfach nicht zum fliegen gemacht sind
nichts an unserem körper kann in
irgendeiner art und weise auftrieb
erzeugen die ganze power muss von
jetpack selber kommen und genau da liegt
der hund begraben
die allermeisten raketen rucksäcke
benutzen wasserstoffperoxid als antrieb
das ist zwar nicht explosiv und sogar
noch umweltfreundlich kostet aber polit
75 euro für einen flug von nur 30
sekunden bezahlt man so alleine für den
treibstoff 2000 euro möchte mal länger
fliegen benötigt man mehr treibstoff
dieser bringt aber auch wieder mehr
gewicht mit sich und man braucht noch
mehr wasserstoffperoxid im tank um das
extra gewicht zu stemmen ein
teufelskreis mit dem auch die nasa zu
kämpfen hat jetpacks sind also teil
science fiction aber sie sind so
unglaublich ineffizient und unpraktisch
dass es sich einfach nicht lohnt
jetpacks in größerer stückzahl
produzieren wenn man jemand durch die
luft transportieren will kann man auch
einfach helikopter oder flugzeuge nehmen
und damit günstiger mehr menschen
transportieren und sogar noch
zusatzgewicht mitnehmen
das heißt allerdings nicht dass es nicht
viele leute probiert hätten
denn der effekt eines jet packs ist
einfach nicht zu verleugnen menschen
finden das fliegen fasziniert und sind
gerne bereit auch etwas mehr dafür zu
bezahlen
teilweise bis zu 200.000 us dollar das
ist der preis den die firma gpt 73
modell verlangt
es basiert noch auf dem rock it welt aus
den 50er jahren wurde aber mit modernen
materialien gebaut
dadurch wurde das jetpack leichter und
stabiler und kann laut hersteller bis zu
neun minuten am stück in der luft
bleiben und für läppische 100 25.000 us
dollar bekommt man von der firma tm
verschiedene raketen rücksäcke inklusive
sind zehn testflüge und ein großes
jetpack training yves rossier cable
rocketman ist ein schweizer ingenieur
und pilot bei seinen stunts springt er
aus einem flugzeug nach wenigen sekunden
freien fall aktiviert er seinen
raketenrucksack und wird dabei bis zu
320 km h schnell
mit einfacher gewichtsverlagerung
steuert er durch die luft und landet am
ende sicher mit einem fallschirm
rocketman benutzer als einer der wenigen
echten raketentriebwerke wie sie im
scherz vorkommen und davon gleich vier
stück eine jet engine sorgt luft aus der
umgebung ein
komprimiert sich stark mit hilfe einer
kabine und presst die zusammen mit
treibstoff wieder heraus bei diesem
prozess verbrennt der sauerstoff in der
luft und auftrieb wird erzeugt ein
typischer jetpack antrieb allerdings
benötigt keinen luft einzug der
sauerstoff wird oft in flüssiger form
direkt im rucksack der mixed uns
zusammen verbrannt der wasserdampf der
dabei entsteht und nach unten
weggedrückt wird kann über 700 grad
celsius heiß werden
würdet ihr euch trauen wie rocket man
aus einem flugzeug zu springen und jet
engines auf meinem rücken zu aktivieren
denkt ihr dass jetpacks in der zukunft
vielleicht doch noch effizienter werden
schreibt es ja auf jeden fall unten in
die kommentare
ansonsten kommt ihr hier zu meinen
beiden letzten videos von what's on die
kleinste tastatur der welt oben und der
hype um das cover bunten viel spaß und
bis zum nächsten mal